un juge de la Cour supérieure de
l'Ontario élèvent le voile sur un
révoltant scandale dans le monde joue
hockey junior Martin Leclerc est avec
nous il signe un texte qui troublant ce
matin Martin sur le site de Radio-Canada
sport
donc écoutez on va d'abord revenir sur
ce qui nous permet d'avoir un meilleur
éclairage là sur cette réalité le 3
février dernier le juge Paul perell qui
rendent décision dans le cadre d'une
demande de recours collectif faite en
2020 par trois anciens accueilleurs
junior alors qu'elles étaient les
allégations
alors oui Martine donc les trois les
trois anciens hockeyers junior en
question sont Daniel carcio qui est un
ancien joueur de la Ligue nationale de
hockey Garrett Taylor un ancien joueur
de la ligue junior de l'Ouest et Stephen
quark qui est un ancien joueur de la
Ligue de hockey junior major du Québec
et les trois à les gays que
les dirigeants des ligues hockey junior
majeur canadienne et les dirigeants
d'Équipe avaient perpétuer au fil des
ans une culture toxique qui faisait en
sorte que les recrues les joueurs les
plus jeunes de ces équipes les nouveaux
qui arrivent à l'âge de 16 ans et 17 ans
la plupart du temps était victime de
systématiquement de de mauvais
traitements les fameuses initiations
que leur première année ou à qui junior
était rendu infernal avec des abus de
toutes sortes des abus physiques des
abus de nature sexuelle des des insultes
homophobes donc vraiment un climat
malsain et donc il y avait les trois
plaignants et il pourra appuyer cette
cette démarche juridique cette demande
de recours collectif il y avait 16
autres témoins qui avaient produit des
acides et des contre qui avaient été
contre interrogés et qui avait donc
collectivement tous ces joueurs avaient
porté les couleurs de 38 équipes sur 60
au Canada
oui oui plus de la moitié des équipes et
c'est il y avait un indice qui laissait
présager que cette culture-là s'était
propagée durant une longue période c'est
à perpétuer par un long période parce
que le joueur le plus vieux le témoin le
plus vieux avait terminé sa carrière
junior en 1982 et le plus jeune en 2014
alors on parle de très longue période de
temps et donc ce que le juge révèle et
c'est absolument horrible Martine c'est
probablement le texte le plus difficile
que j'ai eu écrire dans ma carrière le
juge a reproduit des témoignages des des
plaignants et des affiants des des
anciens joueurs qui ont produit des
acides et après la lecture des le
témoignages il écrit le juge cette
preuve horrible et d'autres preuves que
j'ai lu établi qu'un nombre inconnu de
membres qui jouait dans les trois ligues
ont été torturés confinés de force rasé
dénudé drogué intoxiqué physiquement
intoxiqué physiquement et sexuellement
agressé violet victime de viols
collectif forcée d'agresser physiquement
ou sexuellement des coéquipiers
encourager agresser sexuellement des
jeunes femmes qui étaient invités à des
fêtes d'équipe et ça va ainsi de suite
et ça ça correbare les témoignages qui
apparaissent dans dans le jugement c'est
vrai que ces troublants les gens qui
choisiront d'aller lire le texte le
front en le sachant qu'il y a des
détails troublants mais vous vous sentez
que c'est nécessaire qu'il faut le dire
qu'il faut que les gens sachent
évidemment
absolument c'est un texte qui est très
qui est très graphique qui est très dur
à lire mais mon expérience me dit que
généralement lorsqu'on parle des abus ou
de la culture malsaine dans leur ignore
les gens se disent pas ce sont des
jeunes qui ont qui ont procède à des
initiations au début de la saison et
parfois ça dérape un peu mais bon la
bonne vieille expression anglaise boys
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on constate dans
ce texte c'est un niveau Martine de de
dépravation inimaginables je les fais
lire et des collègues je les fais lire
j'ai fait lire les témoignages à des
proches et tout le monde tombait des
nudes il disait je ne croyais pas que
c'était aussi grave que ça j'allais
aussi loin que ça il y a des éléments de
torture et des des jeunes qui en ont
gardé aujourd'hui comme adulte des
séquelles mais très rapidement vous êtes
déçu de la décision du juge parce que
lui il dit il n'y aura pas de recours
collectif
le juge refusé la demande de recours
collectif parce que le recours collectif
couvre la demande de recours collectif
couvrait une période de 50 ans et qui et
quelques 15000 joueurs 15000 anciens
joueurs alors le juge propose refuse le
recours collectif mais propose une
solution alternative demande que tous
les anciens joueurs
majeur canadien soit contacté et que
ceux qui se disent victimes d'abus lève
la main et viennent raconter leur
histoire au tribunal fasse une
déposition que les cas soient étudiés un
par un sauf que ça renverse un peu au
lieu de reconnaître un problème
systémique et de tenir pour acquis qu'il
y a eu des vraiment des mauvais
traitements que ce sont perpétués de
façon systémique à travers le temps ça
va forcer les victimes à révéler leur
nom et à faire la preuve qu'ils ont été
victimes de mauvais traitement alors
fort probablement que les dommages
seront beaucoup moins considérables
au terme de ce recours juridique là mais
moi Martine ce qui me choque dans ça
je retiens de ça c'est que on peut pas
le laisser une histoire aussi
époustouflante aussi révoltante se
régler seulement dans un tribunal avec
une cause
au terme d'une cause civile il faut que
les élus
Ottawa ou dans les provinces regarde ce
qui est écrit dans ce jugement là il y a
un fort sérieux examen à faire sur ce
qui se passe dans le monde alors un
texte dur oui mais nécessaire ce matin
Martin Leclerc merci
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici